[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm your host this week John
Connolly The Spectators news editor
coming up on the show
the lockdown files this week the
telegraph is obtained over 2.3 million
words worth of Matt Hancock's WhatsApp
messages from during the pandemic Fraser
Nelson Spectators editor will join me on
the show to discuss the messages
elsewhere in Westminster Rishi sunac is
looking more secure in number 10 after
his Northern Ireland wins a framework
deal Katie Bulls joins me to discuss
in this week's magazine Peter Franco pan
writes that Putin is winning over the
rest of the world when it comes to the
Ukraine war the historian Anthony Beaver
joins me on the show to discuss whether
he's right
and in Europe is Georgia Maloney
becoming the next Angela Merkel Nick
Fowle joins me to discuss
and after 200 days of blackouts last
year which continued this year the
politician James Lorimer joins me from
South Africa to discuss if the country
is falling apart
and finally I'll call Miss Douglas
Murray has been on a tour of American
universities last week he joins me to
discuss the difference between
information and wisdom and the attacks
on Founding Father Thomas Jefferson
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV do make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and click the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
Fraser Nelson has been conspicuously
absent from the spectators offices these
past few weeks where has he been he's
been locked in the dungeons at the Daily
Telegraph sifting through Matt Hancock's
prodigious WhatsApp messages from the
pandemic Fraser joins me now to discuss
the messages and how they affect how we
see lockdown now
Fraser thank you for coming on spectator
TV now obviously much of the news has
been dominated this week by Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages the
telegraphs got hold of thousands of them
from during the pandemic and they said
there's 2.3 million words enough for the
King James Bible you've been you spent
the past couple of weeks in the
telegraph office going through these
messages sifting through them
um what what struck you the most reading
them the funny thing is that the big to
me the biggest story is one that you
can't actually put in the front page of
a paper I mean there are individually
there are lots of jaw-dropping moments
but when you see them all as I have done
look at these thousands of messages then
what jumps out to you first of all is
what's not there like you'd think if
you're going to tell children to put on
masks because there would be some kind
of evidence and the evidence isn't there
a whole time and then secondly it's the
kind of nervous system that you see this
is a political nervous system we're
overly worried that so-and-so is doing
the Nicholas surgeon's doing this maybe
we better catch up with her and then
Nick and Chris Whittier said look Chris
is there any scientific evidence to this
you'll say well maybe maybe not it
doesn't really matter it's not worth the
fight but Chris what are you saying it's
not worth a fight isn't a scientific
judgment it's a political judgment
coming from a scientist so we now see
when we were all told that we're
following the science just the form that
took so you get to see not so much in
the big stories but more of a smaller
day-to-day conversations the rule we
assigned is sad they were basically
their mutes quite a lot of the time they
were saying stuff they were but they
would be allowing themselves to be used
in a way for example the aren't just
technical in Sweden who led his response
would never allow himself to be used so
this was very much a political response
to the pandemic with science being
invoked as political cover and
scientists as well being invoked for
political cover would you go so far as
to say that the public have been misled
about this like you say they've been
told throughout the pandemic that a lot
of decisions have been made for the for
scientific reasons and now it seems like
the opposite well certainly there are
occasions where they lied and where the
public were at now misled and I mean
when children were told to wear masks
and corridors for example and Gavin
Williamson appeared in TV saying we
always listen to the best scientific and
medical advice now we've now got the the
message thread exactly that stage and it
wasn't anything to do with science or
medicine it was about to do with
politics now of course that's more
misleading than outright lying Gavin
Williamson we also was fighting for the
children to learn unimpeded from masks
and was fighting to keep the schools
open and for that he was attacked and
mocked fairly mercilessly by the
WhatsApp thread and that's the other
thing that I noticed that what WhatsApp
gives you in a way that no other
document dump could is a psychological
profile of how this group of men who had
untraveled power went from being fairly
open-minded about lockdown within a few
weeks to thinking okay this is what we
want to do and then it got sectarian it
was sort of language you're more used to
finding on Twitter you can now see is
used by government ministers so they
start to see themselves as Heroes as a
word they use quite a lot do they debate
who's the biggest hero and and they are
anti-virus and anybody who opposes them
even within the cabinet so Richie suneck
locks Sharma and Theodore Agnew and the
Lord's they regarded basically as being
in the service of the virus and people
who don't want to stop the virus so
that's an incredibly pejorative way of
talking about somebody of course
wanted to stop the virus but he was
trying to talk about a balance of risks
so you end up with this mentality I
think to me that's what jumps out a lot
but the government was being run first
of all by WhatsApp groups that was never
an appropriate for him
but they had in the way that all
WhatsApp groups do they take on their
own sort of psychology and this
Psychology was locked down being seen as
a political campaign and the enemies of
the world capital of their enemies was
Sweden of course and there's lots of
chat uh any any stories suggests wins
and problems that they get shared quite
Leafly on the thread
um and um Matt Hancock
um talks he has all right I I want you
to give me some evidence about why
Sweden doesn't work you know rather than
say actually Sweden's bought back fought
back two waves with that lockdown how
did they manage it what can we learn
it's a sectarian sort of political
mindset now the language of politics is
different of a language of science the
language of science invites refutation
I've come up with Theory it may not be
right so let's test it only if it's
empirically tested will I believe it to
be true so you're quite humble with a
theory you start you wait for the tests
the language of politics and the method
of politics are very different this is
what I believe I'm going to disparage
and destabilize my opponents I'm going
to call them names I'm going to rough
them up
um and this pandemic was fought using
the language in the methods of politics
when it pretended to be using the
language and method of Science and you
mentioned that that one of the most
interesting Parts I've seen these
messages is the fact that we're almost
in the room as these decisions were
being made we're seeing what people were
thinking but a very odd way did you did
you find the messages from Boris Johnson
quite interesting and sort of seeing the
way that he was sometimes pushing back
against his advisors did you think that
maybe we could have ended up with a
different policy if things had been done
in a different way if you lose hot and
cold in the messages as far as John no
he there's no doubt with the biggest
challenges to lockdown do come from him
he sort of pops up now and again to say
hang on a minute say oh are we really
sure we want to do this normally you
feed him an opinion pool and he goes
away because public opinion paid a major
part in this uh I mean of course it
shouldn't do you should be thinking
about how to get through a pandemic with
a fewer life lost but they were you were
thinking okay we didn't want to go too
far ahead of public opinion
um so Boris Johnson emerges as somebody
who is trying to think for himself you
get the impression but he's
uncomfortable with his gung-ho mentality
of the advisors but when he goes off the
thread then you see them talking about
him like he's a problem to be managed
rather than a leader to be followed and
I think so during the pandemic I think
political leaders were given a lot of
space to make mistakes and that a lot of
people recognized that they were facing
unprecedented virus they didn't know a
lot about so there's a lot of
forgiveness it might have been shambold
Bullock at times but they thought we'll
give them a chance because it's
difficult do you think these messages
are going to shift that view and that
people are going to be a bit less forget
giving of the way they handled well I
think I think you need to separate what
things were like at the very beginning
where nobody knew anything we had this
pandemic hurtling towards us there were
credible threats that quarter of a
million people could be dead and so at
that stage of course the only option
open to anybody in government was to
make very difficult very big decisions a
lot of which were going to be wrong
there was simply no way that anybody in
any country was going to avoid that but
you tolerated these emergency powers on
the condition that you learned from
these mistakes that you will correct
you'll think okay we've got no evidence
now but by the end of April you had lots
of evidence you see how the pandemic was
working you saw how Sweden had turned
about without lockdown you've got a lot
more to go on you would expect therefore
error Corrections taken but what this
didn't factor in was that the political
mind is such that you don't really like
admitting to mistakes you get entrenched
and in a way the bigger the call you
make the more you're likely to defend it
for example let's take um the decision
to invade Iraq on the basis that Saddam
is saying in weapons of mass destruction
now we know in the months that followed
it emerged that no such weapons were
found because they didn't exist so even
then Tony Blair found it very difficult
to accept that he had launched a war on
a false premise that's not because Blair
is a wicked man because of the cognitive
bias which affects all humans
politicians especially so so in a way
you could argue that any 12 people
plunged into that situation given
absolute power a new transparency not
answerable to the cabinet little in
Parliament little in the public would
have acted in that way
but the big question here is not to
litigate the past I'm personally not
very interested in what mankop Matt
Hancock said or what he didn't say what
matters is how to make sure when the
next pandemic comes along as it will
there will be a new pathogen fairly soon
that we've got an apparatus in place and
we have learned the lessons but how are
we supposed to learn any lesson if we
can't discuss what went wrong because
all of this is in the hands of an
inquiry an official inquiry whose remit
seems to be to kick this into the long
grass and to make sure a no politician
has to answer anything until the general
election or afterwards um a lot of the
spectators coverage during the pandemic
was critical or asked whether the
downsides of lockdown are being
considered enough when they're being
introduced for example the economic
impacts the social impacts and so on do
you think that view is going to be
Vindicated by the messages that were yet
to come out and that you've seen as well
um well what I try to do is editor what
we all did in The Spectator was to make
sure that we didn't
um Define public interest is being a
government's megaphone or amplifier we
gave space to all sorts of views
including scientists very critical of
what the government was doing what we
write articles we were very much
supported what the government was doing
we gave a mixed view I was just amazed
that I was here to find out how
controversial it was to give a mix for
you how often I'd be called up the
people saying look you can't give space
to Dr John Lee he's crazy you can't give
space to snitcher group so this isn't an
Oxford epidemologist but if you're on
but there was an idea that you were
somehow letting the side down if you
were even questioning what the story
government was doing
um now I don't I am quite prepared to
believe a lockdown might be judged the
right thing to do but what I also firmly
believe that the only way we can do this
is by an open and free debate not by one
which is edited by politicians or
censored through the prism of an inquiry
so my bias my agenda all the time has
been towards journalism and journalistic
inquiry that's what the space age has
been doing for 200 years and what we'll
be doing God willing for the next 200.
thank you Fraser
meanwhile Richie sunac has concluded a
deal with the European Union over the
Northern Ireland protocol so-called
Windsor framework Katie balls atletic
editor joins me now
Katie you're writing your column this
week that there's been a shift in the
balance of power in the Tory party with
Rishi sunic suddenly looking a lot more
comfortable in number 10. can you tell
us what's brought about this change I
think there's much room for things to
change
um but I think as I also wrote last week
and there's lots of others did the
protocol was releasing as a moment of
danger for Rishi net and I think for
good reason if you look at how previous
story leaders have struggled and
grappled with brexit
um growing a deal of Brussels also wins
over the Tory party has often seemed a
very difficult puzzle and no piece is
more complicated in terms of fitting
into that than Northern Ireland and what
you do over the border and to deliver
brexit and and manage to avoid all these
issues and so the protocol has been very
thorny and there were close supporters
of Russia who were effectively saying
Don't Go Near this issue and don't put
the Northern Ireland protocol on the
back burner rather than renegotiate with
Brussels because you just risk in a
pretty fragile situation if you think
that's just six months ago in the Tory
party
um reopening Old Wounds giving all your
critics a reason to you know bash you
over the head and making things much
harder and terms of governing now
Virginia decided to press on he did
initially delay it
um for various reasons but I think once
was some of the kickback from the dep
and the ERG but over the weekend talks
progressed on Monday there was a deal
but I think so far it's going pretty
well for Rashid neck and now the deal
itself I think
in terms of Tory party means your
opinion it's been received fairly
positively I think lots of people do
think it is better than what Boris
Johnson negotiated now of course the
circumstances Boris Johnson faced were
quite different
um in the sense that you think before
that election trying to agree something
um and and therefore I think it is not
completely fair to say oh Boris Johnson
David Frost couldn't do anything and
received it's come to the rescue but in
terms of what he's achieved it goes much
further there's still some concerns and
parts of this so for example one of the
I think the big prizes of British
University is a storm on uh break which
um effectively gives a unionist
um veto in Stormont if it is sitting
um when it comes to new EU rules if they
pulled a break and the UK government
agrees now that is something which I
think his student is very significant
but you're already hearing well in what
circumstances can this break really be
used if you look at the EU text that
suggests it's much more you know an
absolute Last Resort and so so that was
suggested you are going to keep getting
some EU rules in Northern Ireland and
therefore you know a separation and but
I think even with that you're looking at
a much smaller Rebellion when this vote
eventually comes and lots of people were
expecting you had warnings of you know
100 touring MPS could come out against
this I think the census it would be
under 40. and um perhaps even even
getting quite a bit lower than that now
he's not completely out of the woods yet
we get the European research group fed
in the next week or so
um and that group is divided on this
there are some who don't like parts of
this and we will be hearing from Boris
Johnson
um at some point on this and also um I
think when it comes to the dep the DP is
also divided so there's a lot so it's
not a you know a complete success but in
terms of the problems where she seen it
could have had it's turning out much
better than his his own supporters
thought it would do you think he's been
helped as well by the fact that labor
aren't going to oppose his brexit
agreement
I'm not sure if he is helped by that or
not because in the sense
um Kirsten was trying to sound very
helpful so in advance he said well you
know don't worry about the ERG Rishi
sunak don't worry these kids stuff I
suppose you know about your brexit
hardliners because the sensible labor
party is here but of course a Tory prime
minister passing that business or labor
votes is a very tricky and dangerous
place to be so in a way I suppose it
takes a little bit of the pressure off
in terms of passing uh thing and you
don't even have to have a vote but I
think there is a sense to not have a
vote
um would to would be to
um really rile people who would feel
like they should be able to have a say
on it and but Rishi cynic will not want
to have to rely on labor votes I mean I
think if if he is able to get this
through the House of Commons
um ultimately with a small enough Tory
Rebellion that it does not it's not
effectively demolished his majority that
would be a real Triumph for the Prime
Minister and where does this leave
another former prime minister Boris
Johnson you know he's made sort of
tensive sort of steps towards thinking
that he might be able to make a comeback
for example
um he obviously hope to make a big deal
out of the brexit deal where does this
leave his sort of Ambitions now do you
think he's a sort of a comeback he's
looking a lot more unlike now so I don't
think you'd ever want to completely
write Boris Johnson off and we have seen
that over the years
um but I do think in terms of has this
week been good for Richie Scenic or
Boris Johnson I think in terms of the
law of gravity a good week for Russia
student these days tends to be bad for
his predecessor and vice versa it's um
actually been a surprise surprisingly
good week for cc neck and some MPS
actually in the center of the party
they're not particular senior guys
saying this is probably his best week
today in the sense that Richardson it
looks a little bit like he has chosen to
do something he's not just being led by
events and that means that he looks much
more in charge and has a bit more
Authority
um rather than you know the
circumstances he came into just being
drifting and I think for Boris Johnson
and he clearly has been you know
planting the seeds to make quite a big
intervention over this if you look at
the pre-warnings some resources close to
Boris Johnson but also direct one saying
stick with the Northern Ireland protocol
bill now we are going to be hearing from
Boris Johnson and we're speaking just
before we will be hearing from speaking
at an event we're expecting some signals
as to what he thinks about the protocol
deal but I think that this is not
turning out at present to be
um a vehicle and Opportunity by which he
could start his stage the beginning of a
comeback because it feels as though it's
not really the 2019 intake or you know
the younger MPS who are getting exercise
without disagreement it's much more the
Old Guard Euro Skeptics and I don't
think that is where uh Boris Johnson's
you know comeback would come from so
um it is it has not been the best weak
proportions and so far and we should say
as well it's I'll give you the second
victory of Russia sunak it follows the
departure of Nicholas sturgeon which
while they probably can't take full
credit for he did block use section 35
to block legislation there which made
her life more difficult do you think
it's sort of these sort of Victories are
padding up through it I can give him a
bit more credibility with inside the
party yeah
yeah point when labor have uh over 20
point lead which is consistent and that
is by far the bigger issue he speaks to
Tory MPS and small boats is a bigger
issue
um but I do think for a prime minister
who is coming in to really divided party
he was a big character predecessors
still hanging around I think they've
been a few things which were suggested
his slightly quieter approach actually
can pay off so one I think as you say
was the section 35 ordered I I don't
think it was the only reason Nick of the
sturgeon went but it clearly was a
contributing factor the fact that her
gender self-id policy was so unpopular
and when the Westminster government for
the first time ever enacted that section
to say we're blocking this
um You Could See the s p trade say we're
going to make this a culture War blame
the Tories you know look at them with
their culturals and I think the way that
Richardson went about it which is very
contained and calm and talking you're
getting a legal argument in place which
Kevin bednock did a lot of work behind
the scenes but then making it a unionist
argument with as to Jack fronting it
made it much harder for the s p to you
know point at the Tories
um and I think that has obviously paid
off and what this new protocol deal can
do is I think it just adds to the sense
that yes dormant's not back up and
running yet but it doesn't make things
worse in terms of stormline and it
restores some of the important things
you might need in order to get that
going and you can bind that Nicholas
stage and I think you can argue that all
this talk that the union would be broken
up by brexit I think there's evidence
that that is not appearing to be the
case right now and then secondly I think
it has a potential to improve wider EU
relations and so that could be uh and
also you know transatlantic relations
because the US have been looking at this
very closely but we have the UK Franco
Summit coming out first one since 2018
uh later this month and that is very
important not just because you don't
want to charm Manny macron because on
the issue that I would say the bulk of
the Tory party really thinks is the most
important thing small boats some
cooperation with France could go a long
way do you think there's a risk that I
mean Michigan's obviously showed that
there are benefits to having a slightly
better relationship with the EU over the
Windsor framework for example but do you
think there's a risky ends up sort of
angering them or you're a skeptic parts
of his party by pursuing better
relations with with leaders like macron
for example well I think it is a risk
because there's not results
um so if it just looks as though
schmusing May better a more Cameroon
Approach at a time when the right of the
party think there's too many concessions
and there's no progress on these issues
then I think it's problematic I think
that even if you speak to members of the
ERG who are yet to say the back there's
and I don't think all of them will back
this
um deal they still privately say that
Richard got more than they expected and
so I think at the moment
um it is working in his favor but as you
point to if this now ends up and lots of
talks through Emmanuel macron and
actually no progress at all on boats
um then I think people start saying well
what about going back to the probably
more combative approach that you saw
both from Liz truss and Boris Johnson
brilliant thank you very much Casey
historian Peter Franco pan writes in
this week's magazine that the world
order is Shifting in Putin's favor as
countries in the global South align with
Russia when it comes to the war in
Ukraine the historian and author of
Stalingrad Anthony Beaver joins me now
to discuss whether Putin is actually
winning
thank you for joining us on spectator TV
now um in our cover piece this week by
Peter Franco Pan
um he mentions that Putin is doing a
good job as of cultivating alliances
around the world particularly outside
the West in Africa and Asia for example
um do you agree with that thesis
absolutely
um he's quite right and
I've remembered a number of people
saying even before the war that we're
losing the global South uh and it's
absolutely true
I think that we took a eye off the ball
with the whole Obsession this is goes
back really too
um the beginning of the century of the
new century where uh everything seemed
to be in the Middle East and the threat
seemed to in the Middle East
um which also had military and strategic
consequences and the idea that uh
basically the conventional armies of the
parts where uh I think no longer going
to be uh relevant and that it was all
going to be counter-terrorism and uh uh
perhaps sort of urban Warfare in the
future but um it also meant that
um the
way that sort of the former Imperial
powers of uh in Africa particularly the
French and the British and so forth
um we're starting to be seen in a very
different way they were no longer seen
as
benefactors or at least sort of
assuaging a certain amount of Imperial
guilt by
um support and uh Aid
um and this is where I think we really
did lose out and the Chinese of course
moved in first
and their policy of wolf diplomacy and
of debt diplomacy
um certainly put themselves in a fairly
strong position since then of course the
Russians followed suit and I mean it's
unbelievably hypocritical uh where to
hear the sort of Love Rock who's very
clever indeed
um you know attacking the West for
imperialism and all the rest of it when
we're seeing sort of you know Neo
mercenary imperialism taking place in
Africa in Mali Central African Republic
and elsewhere I mean it seems like
massive cheek but at the same time it is
working yeah through the West's failing
or sort of the success of Russia's
strategy around the world to sort of win
over allies we had uh we took our Eye
Off the Ball completely there's no doubt
about it as we did in the 1930s I mean
there was the idea in the 1930s of
course uh both amongst the British and
the French and nobody would be stupid
enough to want another world war like
the first world war and of course that's
why we underestimated Hitler and ditto
the same thing happened really with
Putin the problem is that we've always
uh tended to make the mistake of
confirmation bias Democratic
confirmation bias
um when we look at dictators and we
always get the dictator syndrome wrong
in what way sorry as in we misters their
actions or we well in terms in terms of
underestimate yes exactly of
underestimating a what their Ambitions
might be because dictators are not even
think in the same way as generals
um and quite often you know they will
have an ideological fantasy as Putin has
its ideological fantasy which um Franco
Peter Franco pan quite rightly covers in
his uh uh article but he could go
further
um when you think of the idea again they
attack uh Western imperialism but here
we're seeing an attempt to restore the
Russian Empire
um and it's based interestingly on the
ideologies coming from the whites who
were defeated in the Russian Civil War
not from the Soviet Union at all and
this idea of Dugan and other ideologues
which does influence uh Putin gives this
idea that the holiest law of Orthodox uh
world uh is morally superior to the
corrupt Western World and that they have
the right to take over the whole of the
Eurasian landmass from Vladivostok to
Dublin as they put it that's very
interesting because obviously we think
of Putin as coming much from the Soviet
world you know he worked in the KGB but
you're saying essentially that his his
ideology he got further he's almost like
sarist and it's oh it is yeah it is I
mean he Putin brought back the bodies of
white generals to be buried uh put up
monuments
um look at the palace on the Black Sea
with all the double-headed Gold Eagles
um look at look at the interior of the
uh Kremlin
um there's hardly a Soviet symbol to be
found
um they're all former czars
um and of course he's great here here is
Peter the Great so since the end of the
Cold War we're sort of inclined to think
of it as the age of American hegemony do
you think Russia and China are now
properly challenged that are in the
properly multipolar world now yes I
think we are we are seeing the decline
of the West for a whole number of
reasons
um and uh I don't think that there's
very much we're going to be able to do
about that I think what we have failed
to understand
were the um combinations of uh huge
changes in the rally of the early 90s
and I think it'll take historians
another 50 years before they can work
out whether all of these trenches coming
together the end of the Cold War with
the collapse of the Soviet Union Big
Bang uh the banking Revolution end of
exchange controls invention of the
internet which meant of course that uh
corporations could access the cheapest
labor throughout the world and also
attract the best brains and this is
where one started to see uh this huge
polarization between if you like success
and
um not failure but I mean if you like
poverty and extreme riches and this is
where the whole idea of control people
have lost control of their lives and
this fear
um has been very much Associated of
course with the hatred of what they
regarded as turbocharged capitalism and
we're seeing still the effects of this
and we'll go on seeing the effects of it
and I think this is why the West is
starting to lose confidence in itself
um even though as Frank van rightly says
you know there is a temporary uh
unity in Europe and in the west at the
moment but how long that will last it'll
be difficult to tell I mean you
mentioned before that the West has sort
of taken its eye off the ball is the
only way it can win over the rest of the
world again essentially well I think
that uh what they need to do is uh
eventually a show and they've been very
bad in their propaganda I mean it's been
absolutely useless in comparison to the
effectiveness of Russian propaganda but
I mean it's to emphasize on the war
crimes
um especially if the war does come to an
end uh how it comes through and of
course is another uh subject but this is
where I think it will be extremely
difficult for any form of negotiation
because it's impossible really to
believe in uh conventional diplomacy uh
when you cannot trust a word that Putin
says I mean he will want to ceasefire
um and then make assurances that he will
not attack Ukraine again but the threat
will be there foreign companies won't be
able to dare to invest in Ukraine so
there is no real solution and from that
point of view but there isn't it out
about it yes he's right we are into a
multi-polar world
um well we say multi-polar but in fact
actually it's going to be it's going to
be cold War II I mean it's going to be a
new split with uh
yeah and you have Venezuela and a whole
lot of other uh countries
um normally with pretty unpleasant
regimes to put it mostly
um who will all band together and be
able to evade sanctions imposed by the
West
um we should probably mention China in
all this they've put forward a peace
plan for Russia and Ukraine I mean what
do you make of that is it entirely
cynical or I think it is pretty cynical
yes
um for China of course the vital thing
is uh
um the eye on Taiwan in One Direction
with of course in the Ukraine in the
other I mean in a way I was wondering
with what to agree
um she uh was who was very nervous about
any mention of nuclear weapons or
anything like that uh might be
frightened of the idea even though
ideally would ever happen
um of if
um Putin did explode a nuclear weapon in
any form but that might give that Biden
the excuse to give say nuclear tip
cruises to Taiwan or something like that
uh which would horrify him I didn't
think there's any chance for that but
you know it must be something in the
back of his mind turning on to sort of
the conflict of new credit at the
moments and how it's going I mean Peter
took quite a slightly negative tone
about how the war could do for Ukraine's
prospects in that uh the defending
country so this is the greatest losses
which are hard in a democracy I mean do
you agree with that assessment that that
well more or less I think there's no
doubt about it that um time is not on
Ukraine's side uh so much will depend on
the delivery of tanks and aircraft and
so forth and this is why it's such an
vital element within Russian propaganda
I'm trying to turn the whole thing
inside out as if it's uh you know as if
it's Ukraine which has always been
attacking uh Russia from the start so
um but you know as I say the West
propaganda or counter propaganda has
been absolutely absolutely useless in
that way do you think there's a positive
element to take from all this though
which is that we've seen a remarkable
amount of Western Unity when it comes to
supporting Ukraine in particular and
that's sort of given us a stronger
position when facing against Russia yes
um I do I think it's been a very
necessary wake-up call
um and you know when man sees um you
know Finland and Sweden and uh the other
and the Frontline States in their
determination
um I'm sure as many
um senior commentators are warned right
from the start that France was always
going to be very vulnerable particularly
to combine this at the same time as
increasing the pension age and things
like that which is so um there are going
to be one or two other countries which
are going to be uh should we say rather
uh
dubious in their support for Ukraine but
on the other hand
the Frontline states are so determined
that providing you know Britain and the
United States hang it hang in there
um I think that uh Ukraine does stand a
good chance but it is a question of
timing it's interesting as well seeing
Putin try to sort of create fracture
Lines within the West so for example
he's talked about identity politics and
uh gender identity and that kind of
thing do you think oh yes well I mean I
think that's extremely clever from his
point of view
um and the idea of you know we are
offering stability I.E frankly um you
know reactionary policies about uh
whether it's about sex which plays very
well in Africa of course yes and in any
traditional societies and in the Middle
East
um and this is where sort of if you like
the uh should we say that the the
liberal extremes richly in the United
States have been their own worst enemies
um in terms of uh perception or well
perception
um but no um I think that uh we are
going to
um see not just the uh uh the problem of
uh propaganda we're also going to uh see
the way that uh Putin has uh uh managed
I think to
um not necessarily out Fox
um the West uh but certainly to sort of
get it onto a back foot uh at this
particular stage and this is why the
emphasis must be on uh the destruction
and the atrocities uh committed in
Ukraine uh with uh they're certainly
rattled them when it was first brought
up uh with a war crimes tribunal which
of course equates much more with Nazism
and the end of Nazism uh as opposed to
uh What uh they would like to project as
their scenario do you think that sort of
hems put into a corner though possibly
if you've noticed that as a war trap
well well War tribunal coming at the end
of it well Putin Putin um has always
believed in divide and Rule I mean this
is where you have all of these rivalries
between the Army pre-goshines Wagner
um the National Guard and so forth and
Gru and FSB et cetera Etc
um so as to maintain his position in
power rather in the same way that you
know he believes in divide and rule in
international relations so uh it's very
much sort of his strategy
um but I don't think that that one is
necessarily going to survive for too
long because if we do see a collapse in
the Russian army in Ukraine
uh or a real shattering of morale
um and particularly uh a threat to
Crimea which is not that difficult to
maintain once they could get enough of
an advance towards Mario Paul uh and
bombard the coach bridge and then
there's a pericobismus
um then he really could be in a very
more dangerous position because his
popularity rating went through the roof
on getting Ukraine back in there getting
Premiere back in 2014 and the idea that
he might be losing it as a result of
this war
um then my father who I might find that
Putin suddenly goes off to the
sanatorium in the old um Soviet style
while they sort out that leadership that
issue afterwards yeah
um do you think there's sort of the risk
of nuclear escalation though in the case
especially when it comes to Crimea is is
overstated or do you think that's that
should be a genuine concern I think it's
I think it's devastated but it rather
depends on how um they do uh or treat
the crime now I mean I think the the way
of doing it is not to start sending
tanks straight in
um it's very much to cut off Crimea I
mean it'd be quite interesting to see if
they do manage to not uh shelling the
Kirch bridge and they've got up to the
pericopter Isthmus uh because the
landscape has said that Ukraine is a a
warrior of Ukraine hasn't he yeah just
sort of in that territory so it's not uh
well I mean what's surprising there is
there seems to be very little
um should we say uh Unity uh in the West
on what the policy should be I mean
surprisingly the head of uh shots party
in Germany uh said there is no limit to
where any of these tanks could be
deployed which implies of course Crimea
um and the Americans have gone slightly
hot and cold over the subject about
whether they're going to uh support a an
advance actually into Crimea
um so it's just it is going to be a a
difficult one and uh
um whether it ever gets to the point
that the West says sorry we're going to
cut off the ammunition uh if you do
actually move in or
um gives it a sort of very reluctant
green light that will be something which
can only be decided when we get to at
that particular Point brilliant thank
you very much Anthony
journalist Nick Farrell writes in this
week's magazine about Georgia Maloney's
vision for Europe the Italian Premier he
says could become the next Angela Merkel
Nick joins me now to discuss
Nick thank you for joining us on
spectator TV now the last time you're on
the show I think Georgia Maloney had
just about been elected um what's been
going on since then and how is she
getting on
well she's um surprised many people and
uh in the sense that the global media
virtually as one warned the world that
Italy was about to fall to a far-right
Ergo fascist
uh politician who was determined to
dismantle democracy in Italy and Beyond
she has no plans to dismantle democracy
and so they are having to change their
tune and they either made a mistake or
they deliberately uh decided to say she
was Far Right fascist
um but I mean I think that
they deliberately
did it for political reasons it wasn't
just a simple simple ignorance
I mean they even said that her
government was the most far-right since
the fall of Mussolini in 1945 which is
of course completely absurd because
um most of the post-war period the
Christian Democrats were in control and
they were um
uh against abortion against
homosexuality clearly I mean Maloney
obviously doesn't oppose either of those
things and so and her reaction in the
reaction in Italy has been quite good to
us and she's doing quite well in the
polls is that right yes yeah exactly um
she she got 26 in the election which
sounds doesn't sound very much but with
her two Coalition Partners um bolus
games fought the Italia and salvini's
uh League
um
they got enough seats to enough votes to
get a very very large majority of seats
in Parliament
and um her support has actually gone up
to her person her party support has gone
up to 31 so whereas her opponents have
her main opponents post-communist
a Democratic Party
uh have actually lost support they've
got 19 in the election and have gone
down to 16 and and Nick so you say she's
very secure now on the domestic front
and you're saying in your piece this
week for the magazine that she might
also become sort of a leading figure in
Europe it's almost a sort of a a rival
to Angela Merkel um how do you see that
sort of playing out
oh yeah I mean that's that's sort of the
main point of the piece really
um she
she has I mean she she has been
very Euro skeptic in the past at the
moment she's determined not to rock the
boat so
uh she she's playing it very slowly
um and carefully and um but nevertheless
uh I mean yes I mean as I say I mean she
if you think about it I mean uh Angela
Merkel was the dominant figure in Europe
for many many years
and when she left
she left a vacuum which of course
uh president macron wanted to fill but
uh has failed
it's pretty bluntly and the only other
candidate who could
so the role would be uh souls in Germany
but I mean he's reliably nothing
really just for dithering about and he
doesn't seem to have any charisma
and and so she so there's a vacuum and
there she represents
um uh let's say a right-wing view as
opposed to a century a center-right view
which has always been the dominant view
in Europe you think she could see her
make make Europe a bit more pro-atlantic
I mean you mentioned that that she comes
from a more pro-atlantic tradition on
the Italian right that's quite unusual
hmm uh that's very interesting yeah
because
um she very very
um
very clearly and boldly
um decided to switch
the position of the Italian right on
America
what well before The Invasion Putin's
invasion of Ukraine uh in favor of
America and
rather like to try and create a special
relationship rather like Britain's with
America
uh where the default position is to
support America's position apart from
Britain she has been without a doubt
America's most committed
um
committed supporter on arms and arms to
Ukraine and sanctions on Russia and
certainly she has been more
committed than any other European leader
I would say on that as well you
mentioned that if she does sort of get
into a coalition with the Epp it might
it might lead to sort of um
Ursula of underline being as being
sidelined do you see that as likely
well um yes you know well that would be
the that would be the result
um the Epp uh just uh is the um has to
is the crit basically brings together
the mainly Christian Democrat parts of
Europe into a group and they have
traditionally
uh had the majority in the European
Parliament but they've never had an
absolute majority and always have to
uh run the show with uh
uh in Coalition with other groups so it
has to align with opponents it's
opponents the Socialists but it's
obviously
um it's been losing seats in the last 10
years or so and it's it would obviously
love to Ally with another group as it
could rather than its opponents the
Socialists
and it has once or twice allied with the
liberals who are the third biggest group
and the plan is that if they do well
enough in the elections
uh the plan would be to get medsler
who is from The Maltese nationalist
party
and a member of the PPE to replace
vondolen as commission president that
would be that would mean a shift from
soft right if you like I mean Wonderland
is a member of America's party the
Christian Democratic unit Union CPU and
um
uh so it would be it would mean a shift
to the right thank you very much Nick
that's all we've got time for but thank
you
Ben farmer the telegraph's Africa
correspondent writes in this week's
magazine about South Africa's crumbling
energy infrastructure with country
played by blackouts I'm joined Now by
James Lorimer a shadow Minister for the
Democratic Alliance party in South
Africa
thank you James for joining us on
spectator TV
um now we've got a piece about South
Africa in the magazine this week um it
sounds a bit like the country's almost
falling apart we're getting blackouts of
10 hours a day it's a huge disruption to
businesses schools even food in fridges
um this is happening in one of the
richest countries in the continent um
what's going on here what's happened
this started 15 years ago with problems
with electricity Supply it's been
compounded since then and got steadily
worse to the point now whereas you say
we're frequently off for 11 hours a day
and you can imagine the effects on
business and industry
um there are catastrophic and there's no
sign of anything being fixed soon
there are huge problems with the power
company the the state power company a
company called iscom
um and uh government does not seem to be
able even if it wanted to to fix it I
mean it's beset by corruption and poor
decision making and there seems to be
very little Prospect of the state
electricity company being fixed
right and you say this has been years in
the making so I was thinking there's
been a lack of investment in these sort
of power stations that means they're
failing now is that right
that's part of it and it started off
with
um uh the government being so impressed
by the electricity utility which was at
that stage
um one in the early 2000s um
acknowledged as one of certainly the
best in Africa and one of the best in
the world
um and government then took its eye off
the ball and decided that the most
important thing about the electricity
company then was to get the demographic
makeup correct so it went on a program
of racial transformation
um got rid of old white technicians and
Engineers through a process of of
retrenchment and uh and not replacing
them and pulled in not only
um new people into the into the company
but also a lot more people so we now
have a lot fewer gigawatts being
produced by almost twice as many people
as they were 20 years ago and
um together with a complete lack of or
not complete but an almost complete lack
of consequence for corruption
um things have just got steadily worse
how bad how bad is the corruption there
can you sort of give us a bit more tell
us a bit more about that
biblical epic
um there are three sort of main types
the one the first is that people are
overpaid for work that they do or
supplies that they deliver sometimes to
a massive degree
um for example the example that came out
last week was a pair of knee guards that
should have cost 17 pounds
um was being paid for uh to the tune of
about 3 800 pounds so that's there's
first of all that kind of procurement
corruption call it then there's the
stealing and the stealing is of spare
parts of power stations the student is
of copper cables it is of oil and other
fuel used to to run these power stations
and then most of all it's theft of coal
now the power stations are designed to
take a certain grade of colon as you may
know South Africa mines a lot of coal
but then what happens is they they
carefully grade or they buy the right
kind of coal from the from the mine on
route to the power station it then gets
hijacked uh usually with the the
complicity of of the the truck driver
um it then gets substituted for very
poor quality coal or even rocks
that that arrives at the power station
gets thrown in the boilers which has a
terrible effect on the boilers which
then keep breaking down
um and then there's the third type of
corruption which is to do with the
maintenance contracts and that is
deliberately breaking power stations so
that you can get contracts to repair
them
and
um this whole drama has intensified last
week with the resignation of the CEO of
escom
who lost the support of government in
January and then decided to resign and
on the day he handed in his resignation
somebody laced his coffee with cyanide
he was not terribly happy about this as
you can imagine and did an interview on
television local television last week in
which he spilled the beans which we saw
the extent of involvement by senior
levels of government in the corruption
and no moves to do anything about that
that's quite remarkable
um you say as you say it's been on the
anc's watch this they've in power for a
long time now um are they are we are you
sort of seeing quite a big public
backlash to this now to the ANC in
particular or they managed to sort of
shift blame to the to the state Energy
company
they've managed to shift blame largely
in in the in the political sense for
years but it really came to our head the
last few months of last year when we
started getting these protracted power
cuts and more and more information
started to come out about the kind of
corruption that was happening there and
it's it's really corroding ANC support
now
right and could you even see the ANC
being removed from power or do you think
that's still a long time away yet no
it's certainly a possibility
um a number of uh independent polls and
also polling done by my party the
official opposition uh shows that they
are now around 40 perhaps less which is
a big come down you know at the Zenith
the ANC we're getting two-thirds of the
vote
um they're now around 40 percent and
it's difficult to see that turning
around I don't know what they're going
to do I think even if they want to fix
the corruption it's now so deeply
entrenched that they can do very little
about it
um let's talk about the sort of the
impact of these blackouts um this must
be having like quite a huge effect on
the economy um especially mining I
believe is that right
absolutely right um it started off with
um Industries like mining having to then
get permission from the government
because uh Power production was always a
state Monopoly they had to get
permission from government to start
producing their own power and a lot of
them have put up solar Farms or wind
farms
um to try and and mitigate the effects
of the power cuts and you can imagine
what happens when you've got thousands
of miners two kilometers underground and
the power goes off you've got nothing to
run the lifts to take them out so it can
be pretty scary
then you also got the uh the first stage
was those energy intensive Industries
things like metal smelting which just
couldn't happen anymore and a lot of
ferrochrome smelters for example which
we used to do a lot of those businesses
have just closed and they're now
shipping the raw ore to China to do it
there and of course now that's spread to
retail too so you'll go into a shopping
mall and the lights will go off
um some of the bigger companies have
started installing their own generators
diesel generators
um and uh but not everybody can afford
that smaller businesses are going under
a pace
um so it really has spread across the
economy and although it hasn't started
feeding through to the unemployment
figures yet and this is against the
background of South Africa being one of
the worst countries for unemployment
worldwide we have one of the highest
rates of unemployment worldwide so
that's just going to get worse hasn't
really started appearing in the figures
yet but we're expecting in the next
three four months for it to really start
hitting right I see and there's been
talk here that you know that that this
might lead to civil unrest in South
Africa um possibly even Civil War I mean
do you think that's a bit do you think
that's likely to happen though
I think Civil War is is
um over egging it a bit
um
undoubtedly there's going to be some
sort of Civic unrest there has been from
place to place in the country uh you
know when a smaller town is all for for
days at a time because I was just
explained that you know the power cuts
from the state power company are not the
only Power Cuts you get because if you
keep turning your electricity system on
and off the local grid infrastructure is
not really designed for that and it
keeps breaking so for example here where
I am in Johannesburg we frequently have
outages of anything from 15 to 48 hours
and there's a bigger chance of the
entire group falling over if that
happens I have no doubt there is going
to be some sort of Civic unrest
um I don't think a civil war
um but it's not going to be pretty
and I think as some have mentioned that
sort of renewable energy can can fill in
the Gap here do you think do you think
that's a bit pie in the sky at this
stage
it is
um there has been a very successful
project by government allowing renewable
energy to be produced by private
companies and a lot of it has become
available but again because they haven't
invested in the grid to distribute it
um a lot of it can't be used and so the
areas of the country where they're
building these projects where there's
lots of wind and lots of sun are quite
far away from the main Urban centers and
they don't have the network to
distribute it
so
um that is part of the solution
um president Cyril ramaphosa has raised
um in excess of eight billion dollars
from International lenders to start
producing uh more Renewable Energy South
Africa
um is a very high coal user more than 80
well over 80 percent of our power comes
from coal the problem is that that also
looks like it's going to fall prey to
the corrupt syndicates the the CEO of
escom the man has just resigned a fellow
called Andre dereta
um set in his TV interview that he had
raised with a cabinet minister that
there should be greater safeguards to
stop some of that 8 billion in loans
being stolen to which the cabinet
minister replied simply well you have to
understand that people need to eat eat
of course being a euphemism for
corruption
my word even that is unlikely to work as
it should because of this inability to
stop the corruption which reaches right
into the cabinet and there's much
speculation at the moment as to uh two
cabinet ministers or two cabinet level
people have been
um named uh or at least identified their
presence has been identified although
they haven't been named honestly well it
sounds like an absolute dire situation
um thank you for talking us to talking
to us today James
and finally columnist Douglas Murray has
been on a tour of American universities
this week to discuss the decline of
wisdom and the attacks on Thomas
Jefferson Douglas joins me now
thank you for joining us on spectator TV
Douglas
um you're out in the magazine this week
about your time touring American
universities with the common sense group
um can you tell us about the tour and
how it's gone
yes um I'm always very eager to engage
in discussion dialogue debate and much
more
um and uh especially with students
because in America as in as in Britain
uh there is an enormous counter-cultural
movement going on at the moment in our
universities and uh I think it doesn't
get uh itself counted enough
so I've been day after day going to
different campuses speaking among other
things about about getting uh the past
in some kind of historical context
um in America even more than in Britain
there is this is wild collapse of
knowledge and context about the past
people students faculty and others seem
to believe their job is to stand as
judge jury and executioner over everyone
who came before them and you write in
particular about Thomas Jefferson now I
think most of us would know Jefferson
housing one of the founding fathers one
of the first presidents you know quite a
noble figure you say these days it's
almost like a Mark of Cain to be
associated with him can you can you tell
us a bit about that and why what's going
on there yes that's right I mean one of
the fascinating things in American Life
in recent years as in British life has
been the way in which all of the central
Heroes have been sort of pulled down one
by one in Britain we've seen this in
recent years with the constant attacks
on Winston Churchill and his memory uh
Lord Nelson Francis Drake it doesn't
matter who you who you find are the
heroes that many of us grew up with all
them are looked at in the same
remorseless light it's even worse in
America uh
um because a new generation of students
and and rather poorly qualified
professors have made Amazing Discoveries
such as the fact that the founding
fathers uh lived in a time in which
slavery was commonplace
um Thomas Jefferson has come in for a
particular oblique in recent years uh
largely because of of a story that has
emerged since the 1990s which claims not
only that he was a slave owner but a
slave Raper and that one of the slaves
inherited in particular
um was was the father of his children in
actual fact as I mentioned in my piece
and as I've been mentioning in
speeches in the past weeks the DNA
evidence on This is highly inconclusive
there is a def a Jefferson a gene within
the DNA of Sally Hemmings the the slaves
uh descendants but it's by no means Kurt
this is from Thomas Jefferson's much
more likely it is one uh one of a couple
of Nair do well relatives known to go to
the slave quarters why does this matter
um I mean it it it it wouldn't or
shouldn't wipe out in any case all of
his other achievements Declaration of
Independence the Virginia statute on
religious liberty and much more but
um but today
um of course it means that the fact that
that not in the country but institutions
like the University of Virginia founded
by Thomas Jefferson uh feel the need to
sort of uh um somehow dispense with
their past or or deal with their pastors
as racist institutions and as
institutions founded also by a rapist
which is I mean a hundred years ago if
you'd have said that Thomas Jefferson
was a rapist uh you would have found
people quite angry that you'd made such
a claim uh today as I found
um in recent uh recent uh speeches uh
quite a lot of you were quite angry if
you say you think Thomas Jefferson was
not a rapist
um so um a lot has changed and it's
changed very fast and with an awful lot
of ignorance do you get a sense I mean
so going around these campuses that this
is a view held by the majority of
students is there a bit of a fight back
going on do you think to sort of you
know view history in a more reasonable
way
yeah I mean the dimmer students have
fallen for the work stuff I mean there's
no doubt about that
um the ones who just you know heard like
go along with um with with you know the
other the other sheep on this sort of
thing
um uh the the cleverer students uh in my
experience everywhere uh finding their
way through this I mean they recognize
that you know sort of uh unattractive
and unsustainable to Simply you know
find guilty everyone who died before you
were born and and it's also not very
interesting I mean there's so much of
interest in the life of somebody like
Thomas Jefferson as with all the
founding fathers who are remarkable
figures uh there's so much that's
interesting about them there's just
nothing very interesting about being a
retributive uh prigish ill-informed uh
individual who just wants to find
everyone guilty of of living in you know
the 18th century tree for instance you
know I mean I mean I mean you know lo
and behold who'd have guessed John that
uh that that people who lived before we
were born had different attitudes to us
on a range of things doubting those
people who come after us we'll have
different attitudes themselves heaven
forbid yes um and you sort of allude to
you as well in your piece about the fact
there's been this big Reckoning over
even the date that America was founded
um I think you're referring to the 69
projects can you tell us a bit about
that and how this kind of influenced
things as well
yeah there's a there's a very very
ill-educated ill-informed uh woman
called Nicole Hannah Jones Nicole Hannah
Jones is not a historian she's not
anything as far as I want to see except
that the the New York Times in the
infinite wisdom decided to make her the
sort of chair of this project that
decided in its own words to reframe the
American founding and to reframe it to
1619 which was the date when when today
is the first brought on to the American
continent
um this is of course a completely um a
malevolent rewriting of American History
it's an attempt not to just say slavery
happened which it did as it did in every
civilization around the world but that
slavery is the sole lens to look at
America through it's like saying that
racism or colonialism which also existed
in in our past as they did in all past
are the only way to look at our past and
of course as I say there's an entirely
malevolent rewriting it's if you did
this to Brazil Zeal is perfectly
possible you could do it to Brazil you
could do it to Nigeria
um I mean the most odious slaving was
continuing in Nigeria among Nigeria you
know into the 20th century uh Britain
and others fought about this but if you
said you know Nigeria is just this
country with its original sin and
there's nothing good to be said about it
most Nigerians were quite rightly you
know chase you out of town and and say
this isn't fair but Nicola Hannah Jones
and others have made this claim about
America they have fundamentally altered
the debate in America not because of the
strength of their argument they never
defend their arguments because they
don't have arguments they just have
assertions and Nicole Hannah Jones and
others will not debate their assertions
in public they simply say they simply
throw out bombs and then say I refuse
the platform anyone who disagrees with
me that's because their ideas their
claims don't stand up to even the
slightest scrutiny but nevertheless it's
caused that another um a series of
serious frictions in America and as I
mentioned in my piece there's a sort of
counter factual here which is not just
the counter factor of the 1619 project
but if we'd have gone back a couple of
decades and said you know what are we
going to spend our time debating in the
world's most advanced democracies in
Britain and America
um you know we might have thought 20
years ago well gosh it was since we've
got the internet and access to all this
knowledge and the opportunity to
exchange ideas we might solve all sorts
of things instead you know we're
discussing things like what's a woman
and uh when was America founded so
actually we've become stupider and um I
for at any rate I had any rate blame
people like Hannah Jones and her fellow
fabulous and and I wish they wouldn't
hold everyone back I mean Douglas you
mentioned there that we thought we'd use
the internet for great things I mean how
much do you think the internet can be
blamed for this I mean in terms of
elevating quite shrill or unpleasant
voices that probably would have been
ignored in the past
well as I mentioned in the piece you
know there's a quote that Henry
Kissinger gave to The Spectator nine
years ago or so he said everyone's got
this access to this knowledge but
where's the wisdom uh he referred to
Lord Salisbury and the way he acted
whilst he was prime minister of Britain
um you have to have time to acquire
wisdom if you just got constant access
to knowledge you might well miss the
wisdom uh we live in a time when any
student can open their iPad and you know
Google something and say ah I see uh
that this fact is there but but the
context of things the wisdom of things
is getting entirely lost in this
unbelievable febrile certainty which is
fueled by very ignorant people with tiny
amounts of information at their disposal
I don't hop on about her because she's
not a very interesting figure
um but Nicole Hannah Jones and Her
colleagues at the 1619 project uh talk
about the um American founding and don't
seem to think that the Declaration of
Independence is in any way a suggestive
or useful or important document
something which I I demure from yes and
I imagine Jefferson would be turning in
his grave as well a bit if he said that
his his declaration didn't matter
brilliant um thank you very much Douglas
it's great pleasure
that's it for this week if you enjoy
spectator TV make sure to subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and click the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
thank you for watching
[Music]
thank you